ich möchte beginnen mit einem satz meine
tochter hatte verletzungen sie konnte
nicht sitzen sie hatte angst dass er
seiner mutter eines kindes das hier eine
spandauer kita besucht hat und
mutmaßlich von einem ausschuss zia
missbraucht wurde sieben kinder soll
dieser mann missbraucht haben es ist ein
so schrecklicher fall aber es ist auch
ein fall der zeigt es muss endlich etwas
passieren
unsere kita ist sie stehen nicht vor dem
kollaps die sind längst kollabiert wo
wollen wir denn unsere kinder haben wer
soll auf unsere kinder aufpassen es geht
nicht nur um betreuen es geht um einen
sicheren ort es geht um frühkindliche
bildung und was machen wir wir bezahlen
den als ihr job schlecht wir geben ihm
keine anerkennung wir setzen sie einen
unfassbaren druck aus
230.000 erzieherinnen und erzieher
fehlen bis ins jahr 2030 und ich möchte
hier die frage in die runde werfen und
eine forderung ich möchte das als ihren
und als hier so viel verdient wie
grundschullehrer und ich möchte hier die
frage beantwortet kriegen warum ist
unsere politik und unsere gesellschaft
rentner oder autofahrer und sind die
wichtiger als unsere kinder
zu mir so hatte
ich finde man kann sogar noch eins
ergänzen ist ein weiterer krasser
missstand der nachdem gleich nach der
gleichen logik läuft die menschen die am
nächsten an uns dran sind krankenpfleger
krankenschwestern altenheim
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter ich
würde sogar so weit gehen polizei und
feuerwehr da gibt es unterschiede aber
die polizisten also die die da sind wenn
man sie wirklich braucht und die ganz
nah an und strand sind es bei den
kindern natürlich neben den eigenen
eltern die die mitarbeiter in kitas
diese gesellschaft eigentlich mit einem
täglichen geheilt also die die für uns
am wichtigsten sind behandelbar
schlechteste das ist ein jeder jeder
einzelne solche fall dass der
strafrechtlich verfolgt werden muss und
dass das widerlich ist und dass ich da
als vater puls kriege wenn ich mir
vorstelle wie meine tochter wer jemals
nach haus gekommen mit so etwas erzählt
und dann hätte ich so ein fall als ich
meine da ist man ja froh dass menschen
um einen rum sind die ein vom
schlimmsten abhalten sozusagen aber
jenseits das ist eigentlich jeder solche
fall ein lauter aufschrei diesen
missstand anzuklagen wir müssen dann
allerdings auch ehrlich sagen wer
bezahlt ist daher muss das geld ja
kommen und wie nimmt man zweck den
autofahrern oder ich würde beide einlass
um unterschreiben und trotzdem
zur wahrheit gehört halt auch häufig
haben solche dinge mit geld gar nichts
zu tun ich erinnere mal einen fall der
odenwaldschule die odenwaldschule war
eine schule von reichen
bestbezahlte erzählt base bezahlt war
alles sehr luxuriös die die die
vermögens und familien republik haben
ihre kinder und es war ein ort des
grauens wo das passiert ist daran sieht
man dieses problem hängt halt leider
nicht immer mit geld zusammen man kann
es auch mit geld gar nicht reparieren es
gibt halt diese form von grausame
kriminalität und ich glaube dass er eine
kultur der achtsamkeit aufeinander und
auch eine kultur der offenheit auch in
der elternschaft und in schulen und
glied das fast wichtiger ist als ob
jetzt das mitglied nur zu lösen ich
glaube auch nicht dass man das nur mit
geld lösen kann und ich gebe ihnen
vollkommen recht das ist ein aspekt das
ist nur ein baustein
ich finde aber schon ich habe das in
meiner kita das ist jetzt werden die
kinder gewechselt das möchte ich immer
dazu sagen aber in einer alten täter
beobachtet da wurden aus
zeitarbeitskräfte ich wusste überhaupt
nichts über die qualifikation ich wusste
ob ich dort jeweils mit kindern zu tun
hatten ich habe ein so gefragter waren
es gerade bei so auch nicht und so saßen
18 kinder in einem gruppenraum betreut
von zwei menschen die das in zweifel
überhört haben und das finde ich ein so
stand und sie haben recht ich möchte das
eigentlich nicht das kann man nicht so
richtig verweben da haben sie vollkommen
recht aber ich finde das ist ein zustand
den wir hier in deutschland diskutieren
müssen ebenso viel in der korona krise
über kinder diskutiert und nie haben wir
darüber diskutiert was wir brauchen um
unsere kinder zu schützen und da finde
ich es so ein wichtiger baustein dass
wir sagen wir müssen diesen beruf
attraktiv machen wir müssen ihnen gut
bezahlen wie ein grundschullehrer er
schützt die menschen die an
schützenswerten sind jeweils besonders
brauchen vor allem kleinkinder die nicht
erzählen die sich nicht wehren können
die bringen aber nicht jetzt ist ja ja
aber die länder nicht zum wählermarkt
behälter wirklich nur die lösung ich
glaube da sind auch politische probleme
also ich hab jetzt nicht widersprechen
erzieher zu bezahlen das ist eine
forderung die es legitim die frage ist
löst die überhaupt das problem das wir
hier sehen und ich habe so ein bisschen
den eindruck hat selbst kinder in einer
berliner kita da fühlt man vorher
stapelweise papier
ausmustern kompletten striptease machen
und unseren und dann kriegt man nach
einem halben jahr und 20 briefen einen
zettel da steht drauf ja sie können sich
eine kita suchen wo immerhin eben so
dass die eltern werden mehr gecheckt als
der kippe und das sind dann sind die die
die kitas sind überwiegend ja gar keine
staatlichen kitas wo noch ein regiert
sondern elterninitiative kitas das ist
ja mit absicht so gelassen damit die
sich irgendwie organisieren und dann
wird das ganze schon irgendwie laufen
also ich habe als kita vater
seifenspender montiert in die wände weil
es eben keine seife gab für die kinder
aber es waren immer alle krank
mausefallen aufgestellt es ist jetzt
nicht wie ein jahrzehnt her ich rede von
vor ein paar jahren weil die weil die
lebensmittel in der kita immer von den
mäusen angefressen waren das alles hier
in berlin das ist die situation aber es
sitzen 200 beamte im bezirksamt die
diese anträge ausfüllen und aus prüfen
und das muss man auch dazu sagen man
muss nichts dafür bezahlen das war den
berlinern das wichtigste hauptsache
kostenlos für alle und ich
das gehalt wie das in berlin aber es ist
einfach ideologie und ich glaube dass
das problem das ist eine rein
ideologische sache und dann passieren
leider sei da so schlimme fälle ich kann
das nicht ich kann das schwer sich nimmt
dieses thema wirklich mit weil ich das
gefühl habe dass und vor allem jetzt in
der panini jetzt langsam die
aufmerksamkeit auf kinder überhaupt erst
kommt und ich frage mich wirklich auch
wie kinderfreundlich ist deutschland wie
sehr kümmern wir uns um unsere kinder
und da kann ich ein armutszeugnis
ausstellen auf unserer gewendet wird mit
letzter gedanke und mache ich bevor ich
darf ja gegen gedankt genau es dass die
pandemie hat der letztendliche das
gezeigt die hat die menge gezeigt und
gesellschaft wo oder wer auch wichtig
ist für die politik und das sieht man an
den schulen das sind denn die ganzen
grotesk
realsatire geschichten und letztendlich
die chance müssen wir nutzen denn dann
hat man das gesehen den gedanken und
auch den gedanken nehmen wir mit in den
abend und wir versprechen wir bleiben an
diesem thema auch dran
[Musik]